et franchement avez vous une fois dans
votre scolarité triché lors d'une
dissertation ou d'une interrogation
match oui et bien n'ayez pas de complexe
puisqu'on vient d'apprendre grâce à une
étude que plus de 70 % des élèves un
reconnaissent avoir utilisé des
antisèches ou avoir regardé sur la
feuille du voisin vous allez le voir ce
ne sont pas forcément les moins bons
élèves qui sont les plus inventifs loin
de là mallory aono clément le goff jean
françois mayet en cette période
d'examens comment ne pas évoquer le
travail le stress la concentration mais
également la triche
selon une étude menée en 2009 auprès de
1800 étudiants elle s'avère massive
cet étudiant sur dix avoue ainsi avoir
déjà triché au cours de leur scolarité
antisèches répond soufflé aux voisins
sont les plus fréquentes les méthodes
paraissent rodez c'était plutôt dans un
examen où j'avais pas bien révisé et
tous mes voisins c'était exactement la
même chose donc on a mis en commun nos
connaissances pour pouvoir arriver à
faire quelque chose à écrire au moins
quelque chose sur la copie c'est des
grands classiques
il a fallu qu'on met sous les fesses et
tout ça tu vas en ressort le tour de
l'hexagone mais dans les brouillons sap
est seul on s'échange les brouillons
bam a lancé l'iphone en fait tu prends
en photo ta copine tu la mets sur ton
iphone et tu regardes les réponses
pendant ta poche soit banalisé la triche
seulement 5 % des élèves ont contourné
les règles en primaire mais 48% n'ont
pas résisté au collège 36% au lycée 11 %
des étudiants triste encore souvent ceux
qui ont commencé tôt alors qu'ils
fraudaient pourquoi paradoxalement à
l'université ce sont souvent les
meilleurs bacheliers qui vise
l'excellence pour les plus faibles
le jeu en vaut vraiment la chandelle par
ailleurs les fille serait plus honnête
que les garçons 35% d'entre elles
affirment n'avoir jamais triché contre
25% pour eux enfin on triche plus dans
les filières scientifiques et
technologiques qu en droit ou en lettres
pour les auteurs de l'étude beaucoup de
fraudeurs n'ont pas forcément conscience
de mal agir beaucoup aussi ignore ce
qu'ils risquent avertissements exclusion
est par exemple au bac
l'interdiction de le repasser pendant
cinq ans
[Musique]